pat's wig shop has been humming with
clients perplexed by the sudden
restriction on travel from nigeria
more than 15 have had to cancel
christmas visits and her son was going
to see his dad for the first time in
eight years none can afford the 2 300
pounds for a quarantine hotel on their
return i've done my vaccine first and
second one
but
why do we have to
pay that money and then see have to go
to hotel and is a lot of money is a lot
of money what i wish they could do is
maybe if you have taken your vaccine you
know you shouldn't be able to you know
go through all that the government says
nigeria has been put on the red list
because 21 cases of omicron have been
linked to travel from the country but
confirmed cases of the variant in the uk
continued to climb and the health
secretary told the commons that it had
begun to spread according to the latest
data there are now 261 confirmed cases
in england 71 in scotland and four in
wales bringing the total number of
confirmed cases across the uk to 336
this includes cases with no links to
international travel
so we can conclude that there is now
community transmission across multiple
regions of england
but the real number of omicron cases is
likely to be much higher this scientist
says there could already be between 500
and 1 000 infections a day the number of
cases are going up quite fast maybe
doubling times of three to four days
it's probably at something anywhere
between point five and one percent
already but these numbers will go up
quite quickly and it is true that fairly
soon if not already possibly now
a few introductions from abroad would
make only a difference
the government is adamant that travel
restrictions will slow further seeding
of the outbreak pre-departure tests are
back for anyone flying into the country
but the disruption is no longer worth it
says this scientist once it's spreading
the additional
pressure from imported infections
dwindles away to
very small contributions so
and i think we're almost certainly past
that at the moment
the evidence from south africa still
suggests omicron is less virulent and
people who've been vaccinated or had
coveted before but it spreads rapidly
and if cases surge here in the uk even a
relatively mild virus could put the nhs
under enormous strain
thomas more sky news